I don't want results we're gonna do the
Bobo ball shootout four people don't
know abou Bay is it's a beautiful
delicious caramel Ebola tapioca the way
it works is reach can't take our straw
I picked red because it runs with my
name I've picked purple because it
rhymes with nurple yes slurp my boba
you got to put it this way right here
stab your yeah I don't have my you get
some boba in your shooter
boom so if you get a bubble to stick on
the glasses one point but if it's inside
the Corgi imprint it's five points you
got one minute score as many points as
possible I just I really want to just
eat it right now yeah you ready I'm
ready I'm ready to beat you I am Oh
i'ma beat yo ass too sticky oh this is
what aliens babies is like but I keep
swallowing them [ __ ] yeah I'm clicking
here
that sound is amazing it's like a Mario
what does that as pitiful ah there you
go
there we go yeah man Boas fella killed
it for a jump bro
I [ __ ] I got way more stuff for up
that you got to that's just cuz I have
more saliva look at our piles look up
piles that rolled up alright nice
rebuttal I guess you would go fight put
it down put it out for them but now this
is gold now you'd be dead
buh-bye